This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。人类出品，必属精品。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不够安全的坦诚对话，而你正与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，去听去学。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索《艰难学到的教训》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《相信我，宝贝：闺蜜说》（Trust Me, Babe）。在《回看过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners.|||与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回看过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《20岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在 20 岁时遇到的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老听众。
wherever you are in the world, thank you for joining me for another episode. I'm guessing if you are listening to this right now, you have been ghosted. Maybe it was recently, maybe it was a while ago, but it really seems to me that ghosting has become somewhat of a universal experience amongst those of us in our 20s, especially if you're someone who is dating or even at times those of us who aren't. So if you're not familiar with the term, ghosting is essentially when someone cuts off all communication without an explanation, essentially in order to end things with you without having to say why or give you a reason. And let's be honest, getting ghosted really sucks, especially when we really like someone or we've created an image or a fantasy of our future together. and I think additionally in a world where we are constantly on our phones, we have technology
wherever you are in the world, thank you for joining me for another episode. I'm guessing if you are listening to this right now, you have been ghosted. Maybe it was recently, maybe it was a while ago, but it really seems to me that ghosting has become somewhat of a universal experience amongst those of us in our 20s, especially if you're someone who is dating or even at times those of us who aren't. So if you're not familiar with the term, ghosting is essentially when someone cuts off all communication without an explanation, essentially in order to end things with you without having to say why or give you a reason. And let's be honest, getting ghosted really sucks, especially when we really like someone or we've created an image or a fantasy of our future together. and I think additionally in a world where we are constantly on our phones, we have technology|||无论你身在世界的哪个角落，感谢你和我一起收听新的一期节目。我猜如果你现在正在听这个节目，你一定被“幽灵”过（被断联/被无故拉黑）。也许是最近，也许是很久以前，但在我看来，对于我们这些处于 20 多岁的人来说，“人间蒸发”似乎已经成了一种普遍的经历，尤其是如果你是一个正在约会的人，有时甚至对于那些没有约会的人也是如此。所以如果你不熟悉这个词，“ghosting”（人间蒸发）本质上是指某人在没有任何解释的情况下切断了所有联系，基本上是为了和你结束关系，而不必说明原因或给你一个理由。老实说，被无故断联感觉真的很糟糕，尤其是当我们真的很喜欢某人，或者我们已经在脑海中构筑了关于我们未来在一起的形象或幻想时。而且我认为，在一个我们时刻离不开手机、指尖尽是科技的时代，
at our fingertips, it's hard to really understand why someone can't just shoot you a message, giving you a reason why it's over, and then you can kind of both move on with clarity. I guess unfortunately for us, we don't live in a perfect world. And these days, even that very low standard for communication seems to have been. forgotten and it's frustrating it stings it feels very similar to rejection and it can really injure our sense of self-worth and self-esteem because ghosting doesn't give us the closure that we all crave when a relationship however short-lived comes to an end and so we fill in the gaps and normally we're not always realistic or kind to ourselves when doing this so we blame ourselves
at our fingertips, it's hard to really understand why someone can't just shoot you a message, giving you a reason why it's over, and then you can kind of both move on with clarity. I guess unfortunately for us, we don't live in a perfect world. And these days, even that very low standard for communication seems to have been. forgotten and it's frustrating it stings it feels very similar to rejection and it can really injure our sense of self-worth and self-esteem because ghosting doesn't give us the closure that we all crave when a relationship however short-lived comes to an end and so we fill in the gaps and normally we're not always realistic or kind to ourselves when doing this so we blame ourselves|||我们很难真正理解为什么有人就不能给你发条信息，告诉你结束的原因，然后双方都能带着清清楚楚的结果继续前行。我想对我们来说不幸的是，我们并没有生活在一个完美的世界里。而如今，甚至连这种极低的沟通标准似乎也被遗忘了。这令人沮丧，隐隐作痛，感觉非常类似于被拒绝，并且它真的会伤害我们的自我价值感和自尊心，因为“人间蒸发”并没有给我们所有人所渴望的那种心理闭环——当一段关系（无论多么短暂）走向终结时所需要的闭环。所以我们开始自己脑补填补空白，通常在这样做时，我们并不总是对现实清醒或对自己善良，于是我们责怪自己，
and we look for faults in our behaviour and look for problems with us. And maybe you've actually ghosted someone in return. I'll be honest, I've done that once or twice and I'm not proud of it. But when we examine some of the psychological reasons why people feel the urge to suddenly disappear from our lives without a trace, it becomes a lot clearer that this practice, this trend has far more to do with someone else's emotional unavailability, with their emotional intelligence, their personality, their circumstances, then our own. So let's talk about it today and provide ourselves with the closure we don't get from the people who ghost us.
and we look for faults in our behaviour and look for problems with us. And maybe you've actually ghosted someone in return. I'll be honest, I've done that once or twice and I'm not proud of it. But when we examine some of the psychological reasons why people feel the urge to suddenly disappear from our lives without a trace, it becomes a lot clearer that this practice, this trend has far more to do with someone else's emotional unavailability, with their emotional intelligence, their personality, their circumstances, then our own. So let's talk about it today and provide ourselves with the closure we don't get from the people who ghost us.|||在我们的行为中寻找过失，并在我们自己身上寻找问题。也许你实际上也曾对别人做过“人间蒸发”。说实话，我也这么做过一两次，我对此并不感到骄傲。但当我们审视人们为什么会有冲动突然从我们的生活中无影无踪地消失的某些心理原因时，就会变得更加清晰：这种做法、这种趋势，其实更多地与对方的情感不可得性、他们的情商、他们的性格、他们的处境有关，而不是我们自身的问题。所以我们今天来聊聊这个，为自己提供那些在“人间蒸发”我们的人身上得不到的心理闭环。
We're going to examine whether ghosting is really as new as we think it is, how we can identify when we're going to be ghosted, but more importantly, why people do it, ranging from theories around emotional unavailability to the dark triad of narcissism, psychopathy, and Machiavellianism, attachment style, people-pleasing, conflict aversion, and so much more. I also want to talk about how to respond. I know our immediate reaction is sometimes to bombard this person with text messages, to keep chasing people even when it becomes obvious that they are no longer. interested or even sometimes just to lash out, I think none of those will bring us the closure
We're going to examine whether ghosting is really as new as we think it is, how we can identify when we're going to be ghosted, but more importantly, why people do it, ranging from theories around emotional unavailability to the dark triad of narcissism, psychopathy, and Machiavellianism, attachment style, people-pleasing, conflict aversion, and so much more. I also want to talk about how to respond. I know our immediate reaction is sometimes to bombard this person with text messages, to keep chasing people even when it becomes obvious that they are no longer. interested or even sometimes just to lash out, I think none of those will bring us the closure|||我们将探讨“人间蒸发”是否真的像我们想象的那样是个新现象，我们如何识别自己即将被“人间蒸发”，但更重要的是，人们为什么会这样做，从围绕情感不可得性的理论，到自恋、精神病态和马基雅维利主义的黑暗三人组，依恋风格，讨好型人格，逃避冲突等等。我还想讨论如何回应。我知道我们的第一反应有时是用短信狂轰滥炸这个人，即使在明知对方不再感兴趣时也继续追逐，甚至有时只是大发雷霆，我认为这些都无法带给我们
that we want and it's not going to bring us peace either. So what is the perfect way to respond to someone who has ghosted you? And I guess finally, how can we prevent ourselves from being the ghoster? As much as we disapprove of ghosting when it's done to us, many of us are still, I would say very much guilty of doing it to others. So what does that actually say about our own psychology and self-concept? Well, as we'll talk about, it actually says quite a bit. And I also think we typically think of ghosting in regards to romantic connections and dating. That's definitely something I want to discuss today. But further to that, what about ghosting in friendships, in work relationships, and any kind of human interaction or communication?
that we want and it's not going to bring us peace either. So what is the perfect way to respond to someone who has ghosted you? And I guess finally, how can we prevent ourselves from being the ghoster? As much as we disapprove of ghosting when it's done to us, many of us are still, I would say very much guilty of doing it to others. So what does that actually say about our own psychology and self-concept? Well, as we'll talk about, it actually says quite a bit. And I also think we typically think of ghosting in regards to romantic connections and dating. That's definitely something I want to discuss today. But further to that, what about ghosting in friendships, in work relationships, and any kind of human interaction or communication?|||我们想要的心理闭环，也无法给我们带来平静。那么，回应一个对你“人间蒸发”的人的最完美方式是什么？我想最后，我们如何才能防止自己成为那个“人间蒸发”别人的人？尽管当这种事发生在我们自己身上时我们深恶痛绝，但我想说，我们中的许多人其实也同样对别人做过这种事。那么这实际上说明了我们自身的心理和自我概念什么呢？正如我们接下来要谈到的，这其实说明了很多问题。我也认为，我们通常会将“人间蒸发”与浪漫关系和约会联系在一起。这绝对是我今天要讨论的内容。但除此之外，友谊中的“人间蒸发”、工作关系中的“人间蒸发”，以及任何形式的人际互动或沟通中的“人间蒸发”又如何呢？
I think the concept is a lot more nuanced than someone not just texting you back after a mediocre first date. So there is so much to explore, especially as it relates to our 20s where it seems everyone has a story about being ghosted in this day and age. The psychology is fascinating and at times I think quite unexpected. But like everything we talk about on this show, there's always an expert. behind any human behavior, including the ghost. So without further ado, I say we jump straight into it. When did it become okay to essentially ice someone out of your life, to just stop communicating and hope someone gets the memo?
I think the concept is a lot more nuanced than someone not just texting you back after a mediocre first date. So there is so much to explore, especially as it relates to our 20s where it seems everyone has a story about being ghosted in this day and age. The psychology is fascinating and at times I think quite unexpected. But like everything we talk about on this show, there's always an expert. behind any human behavior, including the ghost. So without further ado, I say we jump straight into it. When did it become okay to essentially ice someone out of your life, to just stop communicating and hope someone gets the memo?|||我认为这个概念要微妙得多，远不止某人在一次平庸的第一次约会后没有给你回短信那么简单。所以有太多东西需要探索，尤其是当它与我们的 20 多岁息息相关时——在这个时代，似乎每个人都有一个关于被“人间蒸发”的故事。这种心理学令人着迷，有时我认为相当出乎意料。但就像我们在本节目中讨论的所有事情一样，任何人类行为背后总有一位专家，包括“人间蒸发”。所以废话不多说，我觉得我们直接切入正题吧。什么时候开始，把一个人从你的生活中冷落出去，彻底停止沟通并希望对方能“心领神会”变成了一件可以接受的事？
Well, interestingly, ghosting is not an entirely new concept, although I think it's definitely on the rise with the invention of things like dating apps and social. media, both of which have really detached us from our ability to genuinely communicate. But the term actually really originated in the early 2000s. It's what we would call a neologism, which is essentially a new term used to describe the type of human behavior that we didn't previously have a word for. I think it's very much a millennial term. And before it's modern meaning, to ghost really meant to haunt and to be haunted by the
Well, interestingly, ghosting is not an entirely new concept, although I think it's definitely on the rise with the invention of things like dating apps and social. media, both of which have really detached us from our ability to genuinely communicate. But the term actually really originated in the early 2000s. It's what we would call a neologism, which is essentially a new term used to describe the type of human behavior that we didn't previously have a word for. I think it's very much a millennial term. And before it's modern meaning, to ghost really meant to haunt and to be haunted by the|||有趣的是，“人间蒸发”并不是一个全新的概念，尽管我认为随着约会软件和社交媒体等事物的发明，这种现象绝对在增加，这两者确实让我们失去了真诚沟通的能力。但这个词实际上确实起源于 2000 年代初。这就是我们所清新创造的“新词”（neologism），本质上是一个用来描述我们以前没有词汇来形容的那种人类行为的新词。我认为这非常具有千禧一代的特色。在它具有现代含义之前，“ghost”实际上意味着“阴魂不散”以及被……所困扰，
memory of someone, which in some ways could be interpreted as a partial meaning of today's use of the term, you know, a relationship dies prematurely and were left without answers and therefore somewhat haunted by the what-ifs and the memories. Maybe this will make you feel better. Maybe it won't, but people have been ghosted for generations. You know, their beloved would skip town. Their letters would mysteriously be lost in the mail. People have been left without closure and without answers for all of history, particularly in romantic encounters. However, I do think that ghosting has definitely become a lot more prevalent. There was a survey conducted in the US and Canada, and it looked at over 800 participants,
memory of someone, which in some ways could be interpreted as a partial meaning of today's use of the term, you6 know, a relationship dies prematurely and were left without answers and therefore somewhat haunted by the what-ifs and the memories. Maybe this will make you feel better. Maybe it won't, but people have been ghosted for generations. You know, their beloved would skip town. Their letters would mysteriously be lost in the mail. People have been left without closure and without answers for all of history, particularly in romantic encounters. However, I do think that ghosting has definitely become a lot more prevalent. There was a survey conducted in the US and Canada, and it looked at over 800 participants,|||某人的记忆，从某种程度上讲，这可以被解释为今天这个词的部分含义，你知道的，一段关系过早地夭折了，我们没有得到答案，因此某种程度上被“如果当初”和回忆所纠缠。也许这会让你感觉好点。也许不会，但几代人以来，人们一直都在经历被“人间蒸发”。你知道的，他们心爱的人会悄悄离开小镇。他们的信件会神秘地在邮局丢失。在整个人类历史中，人们一直在没有闭环和没有答案的情况下被抛下，尤其是在浪漫遭遇中。然而，我确实认为，“人间蒸发”现在无疑变得更加普遍了。美国和加拿大曾进行过一项调查，调查了 800 多名参与者，
and it found that almost 80% of them had been ghosted in some form or another. And researchers and social psychologists, have a few explanations for this. The main culprit being internet dating, but I think just the internet in general, you know, apps like Hinge and Tinder, they give us a sense of unlimited matches and unlimited dates. It's this idea in psychology of choice overload, but they also have really undermined our ability to communicate and as has social media and that sense of anonymity that it gives us. We have become a society that can now hide behind an online message or an unfollow rather than actually needing to have hard conversations and to express ourselves honestly.
and it found that almost 80% of them had been ghosted in some form or another. And researchers and social psychologists, have a few explanations for this. The main culprit being internet dating, but I think just the internet in general, you know, apps like Hinge and Tinder, they give us a sense of unlimited matches and unlimited dates. It's this idea in psychology of choice overload, but they also have really undermined our ability to communicate and as has social media and that sense of anonymity that it gives us. We have become a society that can now hide behind an online message or an unfollow rather than actually needing to have hard conversations and to express ourselves honestly.|||结果发现其中近 80% 的人都曾以某种形式被“人间蒸发”过。研究人员和社会心理学家对此有几种解释。罪魁祸首是网络约会，但我认为主要是整个互联网，你知道的，像 Hinge 和 Tinder 这样的应用程序，它们给了我们一种无限匹配和无限约会的感觉。这就是心理学中的“选择过载”概念，但它们也确实破坏了我们的沟通能力，社交媒体以及它赋予我们的匿名感也是如此。我们已经变成了一个可以躲在网上的私信或“取消关注”后面，而不再真正需要进行艰难对话并诚实表达自己的社会。
And I think it's no surprise when we see the correlation with dating apps that this practice of ghosting, it typically happens in short-term relationships or in the very early stages of dating when you kind of don't yet have the closeness with someone whereby they feel you would need an answer if they were to end things. Your lives are not intertwined. You're still very much strangers. So it's easier to have less empathy around just cutting you out of their lives. I don't know.
And I think it's no surprise when we see the correlation with dating apps that this practice of ghosting, it typically happens in short-term relationships or in the very early stages of dating when you kind of don't yet have the closeness with someone whereby they feel you would need an answer if they were to end things. Your lives are not intertwined. You're still very much strangers. So it's easier to have less empathy around just cutting you out of their lives. I don't know.|||我想，当我们看到它与约会软件的相关性时，就会发现这种“人间蒸发”的做法通常发生在短期关系中，或者在约会的极早期阶段——那时你与某人之间还没有那种亲密感，以至于对方觉得如果他们要结束关系，你需要一个答案。你们的生活并没有交织在一起。你们基本上还是陌生人。所以对于直接把你从他们的生活中切断这件事，他们更容易缺乏同理心。我不知道。
I think it is very typical for early stages in a relationship, but you do definitely hear these like horror stories about people in like five or 10-year relationships whose partners suddenly disappear and they never hear from them again. And it also happens in friendships, which I think always sucks, you know, when you really feel like you connected with someone and then you never hear from them again, even when you try and reach out. And there's been this like recent trend, recent term called corporate ghosting, which I know sounds super bizarre, but essentially we see it all the time. You go for, for an interview at a company and you never hear back or your employer just stops giving you shifts instead of officially firing you. In all of these instances, I think it's very easy to turn the
I think it is very typical for early stages in a relationship, but you do definitely hear these like horror stories about people in like five or 10-year relationships whose partners suddenly disappear and they never hear from them again. And it happens in friendships, which I think always sucks, you know, when you really feel like you connected with someone and then you never hear from them again, even when you try and reach out. And there's been this like recent trend, recent term called corporate ghosting, which I know sounds super bizarre, but essentially we see it all the time. You go for, for an interview at a company and you never hear back or your employer just stops giving you shifts instead of officially firing you. In all of these instances, I think it's very easy to turn the|||我认为这在关系的早期阶段非常典型，但你也确实会听到一些像恐怖故事一样的事：比如有些人在长达五年或十年的关系中，伴侣突然消失了，他们再也没有听到过对方的音讯。这也会发生在友谊中，我认为这总是糟透了，你知道的，当你真的觉得自己和某人建立了连接，然后就再也联系不上他们了，即使你试图去联络他们。最近还有一个这样的趋势、一个新词叫“企业人间蒸发”（corporate ghosting），我知道这听起来超级怪异，但本质上我们随时都能看到。你去一家公司面试，然后就杳无音讯，或者你的雇主不再给你安排班次，而不是正式解雇你。在所有这些情况下，我认为我们非常容易将
blame onto ourselves. Ghosting is very similar to rejection, if not almost identical. And so it activates some of those same negative cognitions and thought patterns. But here's the truth. It has absolutely nothing to do with you. I don't care how many times you've been ghosted or who you've been ghosted by. The reasons someone ghosts you, especially in a romantic situation, is their problem and their burden to carry. And it often relates to their personality, to their emotional unavailability, their emotional intelligence. And even like we said before, traits like narcissism or psychopathy. So let's explore some of the most, motivations and the reasons why people typically behave in this way from a psychological
blame onto ourselves. Ghosting is very similar to rejection, if not almost identical. And so it activates some of those those same negative cognitions and thought patterns. But here's the truth. It has absolutely nothing to do with you. I don't care how many times you've been ghosted or who you've been ghosted by. The reasons someone ghosts you, especially in a romantic situation, is their problem and their burden to carry. And it often relates to their personality, to their emotional unavailability, their emotional intelligence. And even like we said before, traits like narcissism or psychopathy. So let's explore some of the most, motivations and the reasons why people typically behave in this way from a psychological|||过错归咎于我们自己。“人间蒸发”与拒绝非常相似，几乎可以说是如出一辙。因此，它会激活一些相同的消极认知和思维模式。但事实是这样的。这和你绝对没有任何关系。我不在乎你被“人间蒸发”过多少次，也不在乎你是被谁“人间蒸发”的。一个人对你“人间蒸发”的原因，尤其是在浪漫情境下，是他们的问题，也是他们必须承担的负担。这通常与他们的性格、他们的情感不可得性、他们的情商有关。甚至就像我们之前说的，还与自恋或精神病态等特质有关。所以让我们从心理学角度来探讨一些最常见的动机，以及人们通常会表现出这种行为的原因。
perspective as well. I think the psychology around this is so, so fascinating and it reveals a lot about human behavior in general. So firstly, if you've been ghosted by someone you are dating, most of the time it occurs because of a few reasons. So they did this study and they basically asked a bunch of people, like, have you been ghosted and have you ever ghosted someone else? And the people who had ghosted other people, they listed a few reasons as to why they'd done it. One of them and the most major one being faded or misplaced attraction, but also convenience and to avoid awkwardness, not because they particularly dislike you or because they want to hurt you. ghosting just comes with minimal emotional baggage and vulnerability. It's kind of the easy way out
perspective as well. I think the psychology around this is so, so fascinating and it reveals a lot about human behavior in general. So firstly, if you've been ghosted by someone you are dating, most of the time it occurs because of a few reasons. So they did this study and they basically asked a bunch of people, like, have you been ghosted and have you ever ghosted someone else? And the people who had ghosted other people, they listed a few reasons as to why they'd done it. One of them and the most major one being faded or misplaced attraction, but also convenience and to avoid awkwardness, not because they particularly dislike you or because they want to hurt you. ghosting just comes with minimal emotional baggage and vulnerability. It's kind of the easy way out|||我也认为围绕这一现象的心理学非常非常迷人，它揭示了许多关于人类普遍行为的真相。首先，如果你被一个你正在约会的人“人间蒸发”了，大多数情况下，这是由于几个原因造成的。因此，他们做了一项研究，基本上询问了一群人，比如：你被“人间蒸发”过吗？你曾经对别人“人间蒸发”过吗？那些曾对别人做过“人间蒸发”的人列出了他们这样做的几个原因。其中一个也是最主要的 原因，是吸引力的消退或错位，但也有图方便和为了避免尴尬，而不是因为他们特别讨厌你或者想伤害你。“人间蒸发”只伴随着极少的情感包袱和脆弱感。这算是一种走捷径、
and it doesn't require the other person to be accountable or honest. And that sounds like emotional unavailability to me. And I honestly believe that ghosting is the biggest indicator that someone is emotionally unavailable. Because this practice encapsulates so many of the behavioral signs of an emotionally unavailable person. This is someone who cannot own their own feelings. They lack the emotional skills to openly communicate. They are emotionally avoidant. And they treat connection as if it's infinite
and it doesn't require the other person to be accountable or honest. And that sounds like emotional unavailability to me. And I honestly believe that ghosting is the biggest indicator that someone is emotionally unavailable. Because this practice encapsulates so many of the behavioral signs of an emotionally unavailable person. This is someone who cannot own their own feelings. They lack the emotional skills to openly communicate. They are emotionally avoidant. And they treat connection as if it's infinite|||且不需要另一个人承担责任或坦诚相待的方式。在我听来，这就像是情感不可得。我真心相信，“人间蒸发”是一个人情感不可得的最大标志。因为这种做法概括了一个情感不可得之人的许多行为迹象。这样的人无法正视和掌控自己的感受。他们缺乏公开沟通的情感技能。他们在情感上是逃避型的。他们对待人际连接就像它是无限的一样，
and that people are replaceable or undeserving of a response to them. And according to Dr. Seth Myers, who is a clinical psychologist, he's also one of the relationship experts behind the invention of e-harmonie, throwback. But he says he would call most people, people who ghost emotionally unavailable because the very act of ghosting someone violates this fundamental social law of mutual respect and an even more basic human principle of communication. It may also indicate an avoidant attachment style and somewhat of an apathetic view towards
and that people are replaceable or undeserving of a response to them. And according to Dr. Seth Myers, who is a clinical psychologist, he's also one of the relationship experts behind the invention of e-harmonie, throwback. But he says he would call most people, people who ghost emotionally unavailable because the very act of ghosting someone violates this fundamental social law of mutual respect and an even more basic human principle of communication. It may also indicate an avoidant attachment style and somewhat of an apathetic view towards|||并且认为人是可替代的，或者不配得到他们的回应。根据临床心理学家赛斯·迈尔斯（Seth Myers）博士的说法——他也是发明约会网站 e-harmony 的幕后情感专家之一（时代的眼泪啊）——但他表示，他会将大多数“人间蒸发”他人的人称之为情感不可得，因为“人间蒸发”他人这一行为本身就违反了相互尊重这一基本的社会法则，以及更基本的人类沟通原则。这也可能表明一种回避型依恋风格，以及对……持有一种冷漠的看法。
dating and partnership. This person, because of the way they were raised or past relationships and their inherent emotional unavailability has a lack of necessity for relationships. And therefore, they're very quick to discard people in the most efficient way by cutting off all communication because they don't see the value in creating that psychological and emotional closure for someone else. They also probably never get to a point in their relationships in which they feel the other person actually deserves clarity. And I think honestly, being ghosted has probably
dating and partnership. This person, because of the way they were raised or past relationships and their inherent emotional unavailability has a lack of necessity for relationships. And therefore, they're very quick to discard people in the most efficient way by cutting off all communication because they don't see the value in creating that psychological and emotional closure for someone else. They also probably never get to a point in their relationships in which they feel the other person actually deserves clarity. And I think honestly, being ghosted has probably|||约会和伴侣关系。这个人由于成长方式、过去的关系以及他们固有的情感不可得性，对关系缺乏必要的需求。因此，他们很快就会通过切断所有联系，以最高效的方式抛弃别人，因为他们认为为别人创造这种心理和情感上的闭环毫无价值。他们大概也从未在关系中达到这样一种程度：他们觉得对方实际上值得拥有一个清晰的交代。老实说，我认为被“人间蒸发”可能
saved you a lot of future emotional suffering. So I would say take it as a blessing that this person has removed themselves from your life rather than you having to do it four months down the track when you realize they are entirely emotionally avoided and emotionally unavailable. They really did you a favor. And I think we all know that saying, what is meant for you will not miss you. And I don't think that you are meant to be with an emotionally unavailable person. I think the other element of this is emotional intelligence. When people ask me, why do people ghost? Why have I been ghosted? I always ask them to tell me how emotionally intelligent they think that person was. In psychology, this idea of emotional intelligence is also known as EQ. It refers to the ability
saved you a lot of future emotional suffering. So I would say take it as a blessing that this person has removed themselves from your life rather than you having to do it four months down the track when you realize they are entirely emotionally avoided and emotionally unavailable. They really did you a favor. And I think we all know that saying, what is meant for you will not miss you. And I don't think that you are meant to be with an emotionally unavailable person. I think the other element of this is emotional intelligence. When people ask me, why do people ghost? Why have I been ghosted? I always ask them to tell me how emotionally intelligent they think that person was. In psychology, this idea of emotional intelligence is also known as EQ. It refers to the ability|||为你省去了许多未来的情感痛苦。所以我建议把它当作一种祝福：这个人主动从你的生活中退出了，总好过四个月后，当你发现他们完全是在情感上逃避且情感不可得时，你才不得不去这样做。他们真的帮了你一个忙。我想我们都知道那句话：是你的终究是你的，不是你的强求不来。而且我认为你注定不是和一个情感不可得的人在一起的。我认为这其中的另一个要素是情商。当人们问我：为什么人们会“人间蒸发”？为什么我会被“人间蒸发”？我总是反问他们，觉得那个人的情商有多高。在心理学中，情商这个概念也被称为 EQ。它指的是……的能力。
to understand and manage your own emotions, as well as recognize the emotions of those around you. One component of that is not only obviously effective communication, which is essentially non-existent when someone ghost you, but also empathy, which refers to the ability to sense and respect others' emotions. People who struggle with empathy, many of them find it difficult to consider the impact of their actions on others, leading them to, I would say, engage in ghosting more often as a means of avoiding confrontation or emotional discomfort. and taking the easy way out, the most convenient route for them at the expense of another person's feelings. A person's propensity to ghost is negatively correlated to their emotional intelligence. They typically do not have the emotional maturity to deal with complex human emotions, but additionally, they are unable to put themselves in your situation and empathize as to what they would have wanted if the table's
to understand and manage your own emotions, as well as recognize the emotions of those around you. One component of that is not only obviously effective communication, which is essentially non-existent when someone ghost you, but also empathy, which refers to the ability to sense and respect others' emotions. People who struggle with empathy, many of them find it difficult to consider the impact of their actions on others, leading them to, I would say, engage in ghosting more often as a means of avoiding confrontation or emotional discomfort. and taking the easy way out, the most convenient route for them at the expense of another person's feelings. A person's propensity to ghost is negatively correlated to their emotional intelligence. They typically do not have the emotional maturity to deal with complex human emotions, but additionally, they are unable to put themselves in your situation and empathize as to what they would have wanted if the table's|||理解和管理自己的情绪，以及识别周围人情绪的能力。其中的一个组成部分不仅是显而易见的有效沟通——当有人对你“人间蒸发”时，这种沟通基本上是不存在的——还有同理心，即感知和尊重他人情绪的能力。那些在同理心上有困难的人，其中许多人很难考虑到自己的行为对他人产生的影响，这导致他们更频繁地诉诸于“人间蒸发”，以此作为逃避冲突或情感不适的手段。我认为，他们是以牺牲另一个人的感受为代价，来选择最轻松的出路、最便捷的途径。一个人“人间蒸发”的倾向与他们的情商呈负相关。他们通常没有应对复杂人类情感的情感成熟度，此外，他们无法设身处地为你着想，去感同身受：如果情况对调，如果是他们处于你的位置，他们会希望得到什么。
had turned if they were in your position. And I think that's a good reminder and a good thing to recognize the next time you're ghosted. Honestly, thank God you didn't end up with someone who didn't even have the empathy to send you a text saying they weren't interested. Imagine how much empathy they would have shown you when you were stressed at work or when you were arguing. You know, absolutely not. I think low EQ is a massive red flag. And if someone someone is willing to ghost you, they are showing their true colors. Personality, of course, is another underlying theme here. So according to this psychologist, her name is Kelsey M. Latma, people who ghost in relationships are more likely to have what we would call undesirable
had turned if they were in your position. And I think that's a good reminder and a good thing to recognize the next time you're ghosted. Honestly, thank God you didn't end up with someone who didn't even have the empathy to send you a text saying they weren't interested. Imagine how much empathy they would have shown you when you were stressed at work or when you were arguing. You know, absolutely not. I think low EQ is a massive red flag. And if someone someone is willing to ghost you, they are showing their true colors. Personality, of course, is another underlying theme here. So according to this psychologist, her name is Kelsey M. Latma, people who ghost in relationships are more likely to have what we would call undesirable|||我认为这在下次你被“人间蒸发”时是一个很好的提醒和认知的机会。老实说，谢天谢地，你没有和一个甚至连发条短信说自己不感兴趣的同理心都没有的人在一起。想象一下，当你在工作中感到压力或发生争吵时，他们会对你表现出多少同理心？你知道的，绝对不可能。我认为低情商是一个巨大的危险信号。如果有人愿意对你“人间蒸发”，他们就是在暴露自己的本性。当然，性格是这里的另一个潜在主题。因此，根据这位名叫凯尔西·M·拉特玛（Kelsey M. Latma）的心理学家的说法，在关系中选择“人间蒸发”的人更有可能拥有我们所谓的“不受欢迎的”
personality traits. And as well, kind of these behaviors that we would call very self-centered, very avoidant, narcissistic. And at times, manipulative. So there's this theory in psychology. It's known as the dark triad, and it refers to a set of three very distinct personality traits that are considered socially malevolent and inherently exploitative. So these are narcissism, machiavellianism, and psychopathy. And it's believed that behaviors like ghosting are much more common in people who possess these traits. So let's quickly go through them. Narcissism, it refers to an inflated sense of self, a grandiosity that kind of tends to correspond with their social status and what other people can offer them. Individuals
personality traits. And as well, kind of these behaviors that we would call very self-centered, very avoidant, narcissistic. And at times, manipulative. So there's this theory in psychology. It's known as the dark triad, and it refers to a set of three very distinct personality traits that are considered socially malevolent and inherently exploitative. So these are narcissism, machiavellianism, and psychopathy. And it's believed that behaviors like ghosting are much more common in people who possess these traits. So let's quickly go through them. Narcissism, it refers to an inflated sense of self, a grandiosity that kind of tends to correspond with their social status and what other people can offer them. Individuals|||性格特质。还有，就是那些我们称之为非常自我中心、非常回避、自恋的行为。有时甚至具有操纵性。所以在心理学中有一个理论。它被称为“黑暗三人组”（Dark Triad），指的是一组三个截然不同的性格特质，这些特质被认为是具有社会恶意的、天生具有剥削性的。这三个特质是：自恋（narcissism）、马基雅维利主义（machiavellianism）和精神病态（psychopathy）。人们普遍认为，像“人间蒸发”这样的行为在拥有这些特质的人群中更为常见。所以让我们快速浏览一下它们。自恋，指的是一种膨胀的自我意识，一种往往与其社会地位及其他人能为他们提供的东西相对应的宏大感。个人
who are high in narcissism, they often have an exaggerated sense of entitlement and a lack of empathy for others. They tend to exploit others for their own gain and kind of engage in these self-enhancement tactics to maintain like a very polished self-image. Machiavellianism is another. That's the tendency towards manipulation and very, I would say, calculated self-serving social strategies. It's almost like they love to play games with other people. And finally, we have my favorite slash least favorite psychopathy. And that's actually a personality disorder so someone can be a sociopath or a psychopath, but it's also a personality trait and reflects a lack of impulse control, antisocial behavior and just an overall lack of regard for other people's feelings.
who are high in narcissism, they often have an exaggerated sense of entitlement and a lack of empathy for others. They tend to exploit others for their own gain and kind of engage in these self-enhancement tactics to maintain like a very polished self-image. Machiavellianism is another. That's the tendency towards manipulation and very, I would say, calculated self-serving social strategies. It's almost like they love to play games with other people. And finally, we have my favorite slash least favorite psychopathy. And that's actually a personality disorder so someone can be a sociopath or a psychopath, but it's also a personality trait and reflects a lack of impulse control, antisocial behavior and just an overall lack of regard for other people's feelings.|||如果自恋程度很高，他们通常会有夸大的特权感，并且缺乏对他人的同理心。他们倾向于为了自己的利益而剥削他人，并参与这种自我提升的策略，以维持一个非常光鲜亮丽的自我形象。马基雅维利主义是另一个。这是倾向于操纵以及非常——我想说是经过算计的、利己的社交策略的倾向。这几乎就像他们喜欢和别人玩心理游戏一样。最后，是我们最喜欢也是最讨厌的精神病态。这实际上是一种人格障碍，所以一个人可以是一个反社会者或精神病态者，但它也是一种人格特质，反映出缺乏冲动控制、反社会行为以及总体上对他人感受的漠视。
So if you are high on these dark triad traits, you may be more likely to choose ghosting rather than other direct and more empathetic ways to end a relationship. You know, it's very easy to send a casual, I enjoyed our time together, but text, you know, that's very easy to do. And this theory that narcissism, macculeanism, psychopathy, were linked to ghosting, it was actually explored in this paper that they published in 2021. So in this study, they looked at 314 participants and they found that people with higher levels of these dark triad traits were more likely not only to ghost people, but also to report that they found nothing wrong with that behavior. They found that entirely acceptable. Men in particular who displayed
So if you are high on these dark triad traits, you may be more likely to choose ghosting rather than other direct and more empathetic ways to end a relationship. You know, it's very easy to send a casual, I enjoyed our time together, but text, you know, that's very easy to do. And this theory that narcissism, macculeanism, psychopathy, were linked to ghosting, it was actually explored in this paper that they published in 2021. So in this study, they looked at 314 participants and they found that people with higher levels of these dark triad traits were more likely not only to ghost people, but also to report that they found nothing wrong with that behavior. They found that entirely acceptable. Men in particular who displayed|||因此，如果你在这些黑暗三人组特质上得分很高，你可能更有可能选择“人间蒸发”，而不是其他直接且更有同理心的、结束一段关系的方式。你知道的，发一条随意的短信比如“我挺享受我们在一起的时光，但是……”非常简单，你知道的，这做起来太容易了。自恋、马基雅维利主义、精神病态与“人间蒸发”相关这一理论，实际上在他们 2021 年发表的一篇论文中得到了探讨。在这项研究中，他们调查了 314 名参与者，发现拥有更高水平的这些黑暗三人组特质的人，不仅更有可能对别人进行“人间蒸发”，而且还报告说他们觉得这种行为没有任何问题。他们认为这完全可以接受。特别是那些表现出……的男性，
high levels of narcissism, they were the most, I would say, fond of ghosting as a way to end a relationship. And I think this makes a lot of sense when we dive a little bit deeper into it. If you're a narcissist, you prioritize your own needs above the feelings of others. And that can lead you to abruptly end a relationship without consideration for the impact it has on the other person. These people have this inflated sense of self-importance, and that makes them believe that they are entitled to move on without providing you an explanation and without providing you closure. When we think of Machiavellianism, these individuals sometimes actually use ghosting as a tool to maintain control and to maintain power. By abruptly cutting off contact with you, they create
high levels of narcissism, they were the most, I would say, fond of ghosting as a way to end a relationship. And I think this makes a lot of sense when we dive a little bit deeper into it. If you're a narcissist, you prioritize your own needs above the feelings of others. And that can lead you to abruptly end a relationship without consideration for the impact it has on the other person. These people have this inflated sense of self-importance, and that makes them believe that they are entitled to move on without providing you an explanation and without providing you closure. When we think of Machiavellianism, these individuals sometimes actually use ghosting as a tool to maintain control and to maintain power. By abruptly cutting off contact with you, they create|||高水平自恋的男性，我想说，他们最喜欢把“人间蒸发”作为结束关系的方式。当我们深入挖掘一下时，我认为这非常合乎情理。如果你是一个自恋者，你会把自己的需求置于他人的感受之上。这可能会导致你突然结束一段关系，而不考虑它对另这些人有着膨胀的自我重要感，这让他们相信自己有权在不向你解释、不给你闭环的情况下继续向前看。当我们想到马基雅维利主义时，这些人有时实际上将“人间蒸发”用作维持控制力和维持权力的工具。通过突然切断与你的联系，他们制造了……
confusion, they create anxiety, and they know that they create a sense of longing. And that means that you're going to be thinking about them. And that gives them a sense of control over the relationship and a sense of control over you by using, I would say, silence almost as like a weapon. And finally, psychopaths, they obviously lack empathy, which we spoke about before. But another big component of this disorder and of this trait is that they don't feel a sense of responsibility or guilt for the emotional impact their actions have. So whilst you could sit down with someone and say, oh, you know, you probably shouldn't ghost that person because it's really going to hurt their feelings, it's going to make them feel really
confusion, they create anxiety, and they know that they create a sense of longing. And that means that you're going to be thinking about them. And that gives them a sense of control over the relationship and a sense of control over you by using, I would say, silence almost as like a weapon. And finally, psychopaths, they obviously lack empathy, which we spoke about before. But another big component of this disorder and of this trait is that they don't feel a sense of responsibility or guilt for the emotional impact their actions have. So whilst you could sit down with someone and say, oh, you know, you probably shouldn't ghost that person because it's really going to hurt their feelings, it's going to make them feel really|||困惑，他们制造焦虑，并且他们知道自己制造了一种渴望感。这意味着你会一直想着他们。这让他们通过使用——我想说——几乎将沉默当作武器的方式，获得了对这段关系的控制感，以及对你的控制感。最后，精神病态者，他们显然缺乏同理心，我们之前讨论过这一点。但这种障碍和这种特质的另一个重要组成部分是，他们对自己的行为所产生的情感影响不感到任何责任感或内疚感。所以，尽管你可以坐下来对某人说：“噢，你知道的，你大概不应该对那个人‘人间蒸发’，因为这真的会伤害他们的感情，这会让他们感到非常……”
rejected, it's going to injure their self-esteem. Someone who's a psychopath genuinely does not have the natural levels of empathy to even understand that argument. So it's really, it doesn't make sense to them. They see their world only as efficiency. And if they're done with a relationship, well, the most efficient, minimal impact, you know, the easiest thing for them to do is just to stop talking to you. And I'm obviously not claiming that every person who goes to you can be labeled a psychopath or a narcissist. I really kind of disagree with us throwing those words around, but it is just one explanation. I also think it's important to note that there are some other less sinister, but at times I would stay still really unhealthy reasons that people cut off communication as a way
rejected, it's the its going to injure their self-esteem. Someone who's a psychopath genuinely does not have the natural levels of empathy to even understand that argument. So it's really, it doesn't make sense to them. They see their world only as efficiency. And if they're done with a relationship, well, the most efficient, minimal impact, you know, the easiest thing for them to do is just to stop talking to you. And I'm obviously not claiming that every person who goes to you can be labeled a psychopath or a narcissist. I really kind of disagree with us throwing those words around, but it is just one explanation. I also think it's important to note that there are some other less sinister, but at times I would stay still really unhealthy reasons that people cut off communication as a way|||被拒绝，这会损害他们的自尊。”一个患有精神病态的人真心没有那种自然的同理心去理解这个论点。所以这真的对他们来说毫无意义。他们眼中的世界只有效率。如果他们对一段关系厌倦了，那么最高效、影响最小、你知道的，对他们来说最简单的事就是停止和你说话。我显然不是在断言每一个对你“人间蒸发”的人都可以贴上精神病态或自恋狂的标签。我其实有点反对我们到处乱用这些词，但这只是其中一种解释。我也认为重要的一点是，还有一些其他不那么邪恶，但有时我依然认为是真的很不健康的理由，导致人们切断联系，以此作为一种……
to end a connection and one of those is people pleasing tendencies, which I think is almost the opposite of lacking empathy, but instead having an excess of empathy that it's maladaptive. And it causes us to act in a manner that we think is helpful, but actually it's equally as hurtful. So if you are a lifelong people pleaser, you've probably spent your whole life highly attuned to the feelings of others. But you also have a lot of problems and insecurities around disappointing people or telling them something that they don't want to hear. So ending a relationship when you are this kind of person, when you have this kind of instinct, can be really difficult because feelings will be hurt. So we avoid having to explicitly let someone down
to end a connection and one of those is people pleasing tendencies, which I think is almost the opposite of lacking empathy, but instead having an excess of empathy that it's maladaptive. And it causes us to act in a manner that we think is helpful, but actually it's equally as hurtful. So if you are a lifelong people pleaser, you've probably spent your whole life highly attuned to the feelings of others. But you also have a lot of problems and insecurities around disappointing people or telling them something that they don't want to hear. So ending a relationship when you are this kind of person, when you have this kind of instinct, can be really difficult because feelings will be hurt. So we avoid having to explicitly let someone down|||结束一段连接的方式，其中之一就是“讨好型人格倾向”，我认为这几乎与缺乏同理心相反，反而是同理心过剩，以至于达到了适应不良的程度。它导致我们以一种我们认为有帮助的方式行事，但实际上它同样具有伤害性。所以，如果你是一个终生的讨好者，你可能一生都在高度关注他人的感受。但你在让人失望或告诉他们一些他们不想听的话方面，也有很多问题和不安全感。所以，当你是一个这样的人、当你拥有这种本能时，结束一段关系会非常困难，因为感情会受到伤害。因此我们避免明确地让某人失望，
by simply leaving them to figure it out by themselves, by ghosting them. And it may seem nice and it probably saves you the emotional discomfort of hurting someone. But really, you're doing more damage than if you just fought against your people-pleasing instinct and told them the truth. That's kind of the paradox of people-pleasing at times. Sometimes we think we're doing the nice thing, but really we're just saving ourselves the emotional discomfort of having, to let someone down when really they're still suffering.
by simply leaving them to figure it out by themselves, by ghosting them. And it may seem nice and it probably saves you the emotional discomfort of hurting someone. But really, you're doing more damage than if you just fought against your people-pleasing instinct and told them the truth. That's kind of the paradox of people-pleasing at times. Sometimes we think we're doing the nice thing, but really we're just saving ourselves the emotional discomfort of having, to let someone down when really they're still suffering.|||而是简单地让他们自己去琢磨，通过对他们“人间蒸发”来解决。这看起来可能很友善，而且可能为你省去了伤害某人的情感不适感。但实际上，你造成的伤害比你直接对抗讨好型本能并告诉他们真相还要大。这可以说是讨好型人格有时的一种悖论。有时我们认为自己在做一件好事，但实际上我们只是为了让自己免于经历“让某人失望”的情感不适，而对方其实仍在承受痛苦。
And I guess a final explanation that I really want to rest on for a second is that sometimes people just don't feel safe enough to end things through face-to-face communication. I think ghosting isn't always callous. We like to be nuanced on this show and in some situations it's actually used as a way to prevent a potentially undesirable and dangerous situation in which confronting the person may actually be really emotionally volatile and perhaps unsafe. I do think those instances are very rare though. And in most cases, you can still give someone a phone call or I just think honesty is the best policy when possible. You know, we're all adults. We're not children. You need to
And I guess a final explanation that I really want to rest on for a second is that sometimes people just don't feel safe enough to end things through face-to-face communication. I think ghosting isn't always callous. We like to be nuanced on this show and in some situations it's actually used as a way to prevent a potentially undesirable and dangerous situation in which confronting the person may actually be really emotionally volatile and perhaps unsafe. I do think those instances are very rare though. And in most cases, you can still give someone a phone call or I just think honesty is the best policy when possible. You know, we're all adults. We're not children. You need to|||我想最后再驻足探讨一下的一个解释是，有时人们只是觉得通过面对面的交流来结束事情不够安全。我认为“人间蒸发”并不总是冷酷无情的。我们喜欢在本节目中探讨细微差别，在某些情况下，它实际上被用作一种方法，用来防止一种可能不受欢迎且危险的情况——在这种情况下，与此人对峙可能会带来真正的情感波动，甚至可能不安全。不过我确实认为这种情况非常罕见。在大多数情况下，你仍然可以给别人打个电话，或者我只认为在可能的情况下，坦诚是上策。你知道的，我们都是成年人了。我们不是小孩子。你需要……
own your emotions and be prepared to have hard conversations. Our avoidance of such situations I think it may actually indicate sometimes that we are the emotionally unavailable ones. And the truth is that in any long-term relationship with a partner, with a friend, with a family member, sometimes you need to have difficult chats and you need to let people down. But I think regardless of someone's intentions, regardless of our understanding of those motivations, being ghosted can create a lot of confusion and anxiety. And there's a scientific reason as to why we feel that way. It's not just you.
own your emotions and be prepared to have hard conversations. Our avoidance of such situations I think it may actually indicate sometimes that we are the emotionally unavailable ones. And the truth is that in any long-term relationship with a partner, with a friend, with a family member, sometimes you need to have difficult chats and you need to let people down. But I think regardless of someone's intentions, regardless of our understanding of those motivations, being ghosted can create a lot of confusion and anxiety. And there's a scientific reason as to why we feel that way. It's not just you.|||掌控自己的情绪，并准备好进行艰难的对话。我们对这种局势的逃避，我认为有时可能恰恰表明我们才是情感不可得的那一方。事实是，在与伴侣、朋友、家庭成员的任何长期关系中，有时你需要进行艰难的交谈，你也需要让别人失望。但我认为，无论一个人的意图如何，无论我们对这些动机的理解如何，被“人间蒸发”都会产生大量的困惑和焦虑。我们会有这种感觉是有科学原因的。不仅仅是你一个人这样。
It's not just you alone in this situation. But if you've faced an instance where you have been ghosted as unfortunate as it is, I think there is an ideal way to respond. And to respond not just externally to someone else, but also internally. There's something to be learnt from being ghosted. We're going to talk about that in just a sense. second after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator
It's not just you alone in this situation. But if you've faced an instance where you have been ghosted as unfortunate as it is, I think there is an ideal way to respond. And to respond not just externally to someone else, but also internally. There's something to be learnt from being ghosted. We're going to talk about that in just a sense. second after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator|||在这种情况下并不只有你一个人。但如果你遇到了被“人间蒸发”的情况，尽管这很不幸，但我认为有一种理想的回应方式。这种回应不仅是对外部的某个人，也是对内心的。从被“人间蒸发”的经历中，我们可以学到一些东西。我们将在稍后……在短暂的休息后讨论这一点。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。行业。我们曾坚信植物油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 T-W-O-Percent。
podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. Not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. Not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.|||还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击金·凯瑟琳（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟金·凯瑟琳到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的快克可卡因。需要澄清的是，84 年对我意义重大。不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回看过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学到的教训》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，
because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.|||因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.|||那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难学到的教训》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。
Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones.
Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones.|||搜索 Learn the hard way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了她供词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.|||这需要一大批网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯比安（Greg Lesbian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Ghosting, it takes us by surprise. It's very quick. It's ruthless. And unfortunately, for the person being ghosted, it can be somewhat psychologically challenging to kind of integrate
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Ghosting, it takes us by surprise. It's very quick. It's ruthless. And unfortunately, for the person being ghosted, it can be somewhat psychologically challenging to kind of integrate|||这里是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。“人间蒸发”让我们措手不及。它非常快。它冷酷无情。不幸的是，对于被“人间蒸发”的人来说，在心理上将这段经历消化吸收并从中走出来，
and get over it. You know, you feel angry, you're going to feel rejected. Your self-esteem may even lapse, or you will respond with cynicism around dating and connection, you know, giving up on love, being like, I cannot take another ghost. I cannot take another instance of rejection. So why is that? There is this really fascinating article. I really actually would recommend it for further reading if you're interested. It's called in defense of ghosting. And the author explains how at the very heart of ghosting is rejection. And the reason we find it so difficult is because we wanted a different outcome.
and get over it. You know, you feel angry, you're going to feel rejected. Your self-esteem may even lapse, or you will respond with cynicism around dating and connection, you know, giving up on love, being like, I cannot take another ghost. I cannot take another instance of rejection. So why is that? There is this really fascinating article. I really actually would recommend it for further reading if you're interested. It's called in defense of ghosting. And the author explains how at the very heart of ghosting is rejection. And the reason we find it so difficult is because we wanted a different outcome.|||可能会在心理上具有一定的挑战性。你知道的，你会感到愤怒，你会感到被拒绝。你的自尊心甚至可能会下滑，或者你会带着愤世嫉俗的态度来对待约会和人际连接，你知道的，放弃爱情，觉得：我再也经不起另一次“人间蒸发”了。我再也经不起另一次被拒绝了。那么为什么会这样呢？有一篇非常迷人的文章。如果你感兴趣的话，我真的非常推荐你阅读一下。它叫《为“人间蒸发”辩护》（In Defense of Ghosting）。作者解释了“人间蒸发”的核心其实就是拒绝。我们之所以觉得它如此困难，是因为我们想要一个不同的结局。
And that's something that we can't always accept. Psychologically, as a species, we crave closure. Any relationship, however short-lived it was, it requires us to put partial trust in another person that they will treat us well and respect our best interests. You know, without that, there really wouldn't have even been that spark. there wouldn't have been that connection. So whether it's been a few days, a few weeks, a few months, our brains crave an ending that
And that's something that we can't always accept. Psychologically, as a species, we crave closure. Any relationship, however short-lived it was, it requires us to put partial trust in another person that they will treat us well and respect our best interests. You know, without that, there really wouldn't have even been that spark. there wouldn't have been that connection. So whether it's been a few days, a few weeks, a few months, our brains crave an ending that|||而这是我们并不总能接受的事情。在心理上，作为人类这个物种，我们渴望闭环。任何关系，无论多么短暂，都要求我们对另一个人给予部分信任，相信他们会善待我们并尊重我们的最佳利益。你知道的，如果没有这一点，甚至都不会产生那种火花，也不会有那种连接。因此，无论是几天、几周还是几个月，我们的大脑都渴望一个……的结局。
gives us answers and we respond poorly to situations where there are blanks or there is ambiguity. And it kind of essentially feels like it renders us powerless and leaves us with no opportunity to ask questions and to be provided with the information that would help us to emotionally process the experience. That silence that we hear, that there's nothingness there, in order to compensate for that, we provide our own answers to fill in the blanks and to give ourselves the closure that we desire. And often our explanations typically conclude that there was a problem with us rather than them. You know, we were too loud. We were too unattractive. We were too boring. And none of those things are correct. Absolutely none of them. They were the immature one.
给我们提供答案，而我们对出现空白或模棱两可的情况反应很差。这基本上让我们觉得自己无能为力，剥夺了我们提问以及获取信息的机会，而这些信息本可以帮助我们从情感上消化这段经历。我们听到的那种沉默，那种虚无，为了弥补这一点，我们提供自己的答案来填补空白，给我们所渴望的解脱。而且通常我们的解释最终都归结为我们自身有问题，而不是他们有问题。你知道，我们太吵了。我们太没有吸引力了。我们太无聊了。然而这些都不是真的。绝对没有一个是真的。不成熟的是他们。
They were emotionally unavailable. They were childish. You know, any human with a properly developed frontal lobe knows how to be kind but honest and knows how to type out a text message providing you with an explanation. This has absolutely nothing to do with you. Even if you saw it coming, even if, you know, maybe the date was a little bit awkward, you still deserve an answer, right? That's just a genuine level of human respect. I think the other reason, though, that we find it so difficult is because we use social cues from others to regulate our emotions,
他们情感上无法沟通。他们很幼稚。你知道，任何一个拥有正常发育的前额叶皮层的成年人都知道如何做到既友善又诚实，也知道如何打字发一条带解释的短信。这跟你绝对没有任何关系。即使你有所预料，即使，你知道，也许约会时有点尴尬，你仍然配得上一个答案，对吧？这只是一种真诚的人类尊重水平。不过，我认为我们觉得这么难的另一个原因，是我们利用他人的社交线索来调节自己的情绪，
but also to provide us feedback around our value and our worthiness. So when we are rejected in such a callous way, we don't have any sense of how to react, because, well, they've kind of given us nothing to work with. So we don't really know what we can fix. We don't know how to respond. So according to this article by Psychology Today, an amazing resource, by the way, if you're a psychology student out there, this is a great resource to use.
同时也为了给我们提供关于我们的价值和自我价值的反馈。因此，当我们以如此冷酷的方式被拒绝时，我们根本不知道该做何反应，因为，好吧，他们给我们留下的东西太少了。所以我们真的不知道能修复什么。我们不知道该如何回应。因此，根据《今日心理学》这篇极好的文章——顺便说一句，如果你是一名心理学专业的学生，这是一个非常棒的参考资料。
But social cues, as we know, they allow us to regulate our own behavior according to how other people react and the information that other people are giving us, either through their words or through their actions. but when we are ghosted, it really deprives you of those usual social cues, and it creates a sense of emotional dysregulation where you feel out of control. It's also just the science of good old faction, like rejection, which we all know is awful, and we've all been rejected. Ghosting is a form of rejection. And from a psychological standpoint, this really does just threaten our basic human need for belongingness and for social connection.
但正如我们所知，社交线索能让我们根据别人的反应以及别人通过言语或行动提供给我们的信息来调节自己的行为。然而当我们被“放鸽子”时，它确实剥夺了你那些平常的社交线索，并造成了一种情绪失调感，让你觉得一切失控了。这其实也是老套的拒绝科学，就像我们都知道拒绝是多么糟糕，而且我们都曾被拒绝过。不告而别（Ghosting）就是拒绝的一种形式。从心理学的角度来看，这确实威胁到了我们对归属感和社交连接的基本人类需求。
When we experience this, it can trigger a range of negative emotions like sadness, like shame, even anger, because the brain perceives rejection and ghosting as a threat to our social standing, as a threat to how accepted we are, as a threat to our inclusion in the in-group, and that activates some of the same neural pathways that are associated with physical pain. It's an evolutionary siren, an evolutionary alarm in our head that goes, oh my gosh, this person doesn't like me. Will that mean that I survive? Because if I'm not liked historically, that meant I would not survive and I would not live to pass on my genetics. I would not live to see my old age. And that psychological hurt can lead to a diminished sense of self-worth and self-esteem. And we begin to
当我们经历这一切时，它会引发一系列负面情绪，比如悲伤、羞耻，甚至是愤怒，因为大脑将拒绝和断联视为对我们社会地位的威胁，对我们被接受程度的威胁，对我们融入群体的威胁，这会激活与身体疼痛相关的某些相同的神经通路。这是我们脑海中的一个进化警报，一个进化警号，它在喊着：噢天哪，这个人不喜欢我。这是否意味着我能生存？因为从历史上看，如果不被人喜欢，就意味着我无法生存，我也无法活下去繁衍后代。我无法活到年老。这种心理伤害会导致自我价值感和自尊心下降。我们开始
I would say really it internalized that. You know, there is no outward explanation provided by that person. I've said that a million times, but no one is giving us an answer. We have to come up with that ourselves. So it really destabilizes our self-perception and our worldview, and it leaves us feeling particularly vulnerable and particularly uncertain. So what do we do now? What are the next steps here?
我想说的是，真的将其内化了。你知道，那个人并没有提供任何外在的解释。我已经说过无数次了，但没有人给我们答案。我们必须自己想出答案。所以这确实动摇了我们的自我认知和世界观，让我们感到格外脆弱和不确定。那么我们现在该怎么办？接下来的步骤是什么？
What is the best way to respond? I always say this on this show. and it is a very deep personal philosophy of mine, but no response is the most powerful response, especially when we consider why people ghost and the personality traits that may be inherent within them, things like narcissism, things like psychopathy, things like Machiavellianism.
最好的回应方式是什么？我在这档节目中经常这么说，这也是我非常深度的个人哲学，但没有回应就是最有力的回应，尤其是当我们考虑到人们为什么会玩失踪，以及他们内在可能存在的性格特征时，比如自恋、精神病态、马基雅维利主义。
Remember, for some people, not all, but for some, ghosting is a way of asserting their power and their sense of entitlement. they may expect you to lash out. They may expect you to act needy and to triple message them, and that only feeds their ego in those instances. If you're really craving closure, I think a message template that I read that I think is spectacular
记住，对某些人来说——不是所有人，但对某些人来说——不告而别是他们宣示权力和特权感的一种方式。他们可能预料到你会大发雷霆。他们可能预料到你会表现得死缠烂打并连续发三条信息，而在那种情况下，这只会助长他们的自负。如果你真的渴望得到一个了结，我觉得我读到过的一个短信模板非常棒，
and that you could send would be, you know, hey, I haven't heard from you all in a while. I'm not sure what happened, but I don't want to pursue this. I think my time is too valuable, and I don't want to leave this door open. best of luck. That focus on, this is my choice. You may have ghosted me, but I am the one who's actually choosing to officially close the door is, I think, a very powerful statement, not just to them, but to yourself that you have agency in this situation. Honestly, I don't think texting people
而且你可以发过去，比如：嘿，我好久没听到你的消息了。我不知道发生了什么，但我不想再继续下去了。我觉得我的时间太宝贵了，我不想再敞开这扇门。祝你好运。这种专注于“这是我的选择”的姿态——你可能冷落了我，但我才是那个真正选择正式关上门的人——我认为这是一个非常有力的声明，不仅是对他们，也是对你自己，即你在这种情况下拥有自主权。老实说，我觉得发短信给
when they've ghosted you is advisable, but I would say that if you really need that tangible, solid ending, you really need that closure. Make sure you frame it in a way that puts you you at the epicenter of control that gives you the sense of agency. But I really do think silence is the loudest sound when it comes to ghosting. I always try and think about this. Remember how you reacted to their silence? Remember how it left you feeling really hungry for more? Well, give them that feeling in return.
那些对你不告而别的人是不可取的，但我必须说，如果你真的需要那个切实、坚实的结局，你真的需要那个了结。确保你以一种让自己处于控制中心的方式来构建它，从而赋予你自主权。但我真的认为，在不告而别这件事上，沉默是最响亮的声音。我总是试着去思考这一点。还记得你是如何对他们的沉默作出反应的吗？还记得它如何让你感到对更多答案极其渴望吗？好吧，把那种感觉回馈给他们。
Prove to them that you know your value and your worth and you're not going to beg. You're not going to ask for attention. you have an abundance of connections and options, and if they decide to treat you with disrespect, if they decide to treat you this way, that is entirely they're right, but you're not going to argue with them. These individuals, I don't think they deserve a response. You know, they didn't care enough about your emotional needs, and they don't really require any more thought from you if that's the case.
向他们证明你清楚自己的价值和尊严，你不会去乞求。你不会去索取关注；你拥有大量的社交关系和选择，如果他们决定对你不尊重，如果他们决定这样对待你，那是他们的权利，但你不会跟他们争论。这些家伙，我认为他们不配得到回应。你知道，他们根本不在乎你的情感需求，如果真是这样，他们真的不值得你花心思去想。
Sometimes that urge is strong, like I said, it's only psychologically natural to want answers, So if you're very much opposed to sending a text message, as I would probably advise you don't, the best way to avoid that is to remove them as a potential stimulus. So out of sight, out of mind, unfollow, delete your text thread, remove anything that might trigger you or provide a cue that you should message them or that you should reach out. And if you do see them, I would always say be kind. showed them that their actions did absolutely nothing to shake your self-confidence, nothing to shake your resolve. They did you a favor by removing themselves from your life. You're also not going to change their mind.
有时候这种冲动很强烈，就像我说的，想要答案在心理上是完全自然的，所以如果你非常反对发短信——正如我可能建议你不要那样做的那样——避免这种情况的最好方法就是把他们当作潜在的刺激源移除。眼不见，心不烦，取消关注，删除聊天记录，移除任何可能触发你或者给你提供发信息暗示的东西。如果你真的遇到他们，我总是会建议要友善。向他们展示他们的行为根本无法动摇你的自信，无法动摇你的决心。他们把自己从你的生活里清除出去，其实是在帮你的忙。你也无法改变他们的想法。
That's an important thing to remember as well. And I think it's also valuable to ask, you know, do you even want to change their mind? This person is most likely emotionally unavailable, emotionally unintelligent, or they are an unrestrained, unself-aware people-pleaser, what kind of future would you have had with them anyways? I would say probably not an emotionally satisfying one. Their opinion really doesn't mean anything to you. This person barely knew you.
这也是一件需要记住的重要事情。而且我认为问这样一个问题也很有价值：你知道，你甚至想改变他们的想法吗？这个人多半在情感上无法沟通、情感智力低下，或者是一个不知变通、缺乏自我意识的老好人，你无论如何能跟他们有什么未来呢？我想说，大概不会是一个情感上令人满意的未来。他们的意见对你来说真的毫无意义。这个人根本不了解你。
You barely knew them. To the point where they couldn't even provide you with a message or the closure or the empathy or the answers that you deserve. So I think the best is yet to come. and I would say my final piece of advice for getting over, you know, the sense of being ghosted and kind of the pain of being ghosted is to let that disappointment teach you a lesson and allow it to inform your own actions and your own empathy. Meet their lack of empathy with an abundance of your own. And next time you're in a situation where you're feeling the urge to just kind of
你也不太了解他们。以至于他们甚至无法给你发一条信息、给你一个了结、给你同理心或你应得的答案。所以我认为最好的还在后头。我想说，关于克服被冷落的感觉以及被冷落带来的痛苦的最后一条建议是，让那种失望给你上一课，让它来指导你自己的行动和你的同理心。用你极其丰富的同理心去应对他们缺乏同理心的行为。下次当你处于一种感觉想要
ice someone out, think about what you would want. Think about this. experience. You know, we've all experienced that impulse because sometimes I think in the chaos of life, the last thing we want to do is have to deal with disappointing someone. But all of these experiences, I do think make us a more genuine, authentic, empathetic person. And you don't want to stoop to their level. You don't want to be someone who ghost someone. A friend of mine actually has this really amazing anti-ghosting message she uses. And I had to ask her one day to like send it to me. because I think it's so valuable. It goes something, I think it's pretty simple.
把某人冷落一旁的冲动时，想想你会想要什么。想想这段经历。你知道，我们都经历过那种冲动，因为有时我认为在生活的混乱中，我们最不想做的事情就是去处理让别人失望的情况。但我确实认为，所有这些经历都会让我们成为一个更真诚、更真实、更有同理心的人。你不想自降身价。你不想成为那种对别人不告而别的人。我的一个朋友实际上有一条非常棒的反不告而别短信，她经常使用。我有一天不得不让她发给我，因为我觉得它太有价值了。它大概是这样的，我觉得很简单。
It's like, hey, I really enjoyed getting to know you, and you're a wonderful person. Unfortunately, I don't see this going any further, but I truly wish you the best. Simple, closure, for you and for them. And it saves the bad blood of, you know, having to run into someone at a party and awkwardly pretend, like, you didn't fully ignore them.
大概是：嘿，我真的很享受了解你的过程，你是一个很棒的人。不幸的是，我看不出我们还能进一步发展，但我真心祝你一切都好。简单，有个了结，对你对他们都好。而且它避免了这种尴尬：比如在派对上偶遇某人，还要尴尬地假装好像你没有彻底忽视对方。
You know, honesty is always the best policy. We are not here to be ghosting people whoever they are in your life. And finally, if I haven't said it enough, you are not accountable for their actions or their choices. You are not at fault. That was their decision. And the best way you could move forward
你知道，诚实永远是上策。无论他们在你的人生中是谁，我们都不是来对别人不告而别的。最后，如果我还没强调够的话，你无需为他们的行为或选择负责。这不是你的错。那是他们做出的决定。你能前进的最好方式
is to kind of rest back in your own power, is to remind you that you are confident, remind yourself that you are self-assured, that you are spectacular, and the right person would never think of treating you this way. Remember, no one's actions, can hurt you if you don't let it. This person was never going to be good enough for you. They revealed that for you. They did you a favor. And the best way you can respond to that is by
就是重新掌握你自己的力量，提醒自己你是自信的，提醒自己你是坚定的，你是出类拔萃的，对的人绝不会想要这样对待你。记住，如果没有你的允许，任何人的行为都无法伤害你。这个人永远配不上你。他们为你揭示了这一点。他们是在帮你的忙。而你对此做出回应的最好方式就是
taking their answer, taking their response and moving on. You don't need to beg. This is not the person for you. This is just a blip on your radar. I just think life gets so much better when we realize that other people's opinions don't matter unless we let them. And this is really one of those instances where this person was like a complete stranger to you, perhaps even a couple of weeks ago. And they will become a stranger again. And there is no harm in that. So I really hope that you enjoy this episode.
接受他们的答案，接受他们的回应并继续前行。你不需要乞求。这个人不适合你。这只是你雷达上的一个微小波折。我只是觉得，当我们意识到除非我们允许，否则别人的意见根本不重要时，生活会变得好得多。这确实是那种实例之一：这个人对你来说就像一个完全的陌生人，也许就在几周前。而他们又会重新变回陌生人。这没有任何害处。所以我真的很希望你喜欢这一集。
I really did. I love talking about ghosting. It's something that my friends and I talk about quite a bit, actually, around who we've been ghosted by, but also when did it become socially acceptable to do that? And I do think that the rise of like technology and like social media and online interactions have really lessened our sense of accountability when it comes to other people's emotions. That's just one of my theories. But if you have been ghosted, however recent it was, I hope this episode provided you
我确实很喜欢。我很喜欢谈论不告而别。这实际上是我和朋友们经常谈论的事情，比如我们被谁冷落过，以及什么时候这种做法在社交上变得可以接受了？而且我确实认为科技、社交媒体和线上互动的兴起，确实减弱了我们在面对他人情绪时的责任感。这只是我的理论之一。但如果你被不告而别了，无论这发生在多久以前，我希望这一集能为你提供
with the closure that that person didn't. You really do deserve it. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, or if there is someone in your life who really needs to hear this, you should send them a sneaky link. Not that kind of sneaky link. Just send them a link to the show. Just share it forward.
那个人没有给你的了结。你真的应得的。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，或者你生命中有谁真的很需要听听这个，你应该给他们发个“秘密链接”。不是那种秘密链接。只需发一个节目的链接给他们。把它分享出去。
And maybe you'll provide them with some insights they didn't previously have. Please also feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, IHart, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show to grow. It helps it reach new people. It makes my day. I say this all the time, but I read every single. one of your reviews, especially when I'm like having a hard day. It's really nice to know there's such a gorgeous, wonderful community out there of people who actually really care about this and who
也许你会为他们提供一些他们以前没有的见解。也请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify、iHeart 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长有很大帮助。它有助于接触到新的人。这让我一整天都心情大好。我总是这么说，但我会阅读你们的每一条评论，尤其是当我遇到艰难的一天时。知道外面有这样一个美好、棒极了的社群，里面的人真正关心这些并且
really care about their health. They care about their well-being. They want to know the psychology. That's just so amazing. We really do have the best community. So thank you so much. And if you have an episode suggestion, I almost forgot. Please follow me at that psychology podcast. I love hearing what your experiences are and how we could apply some of the science to them. So come come of a chat over there. Come send through an idea. We hope to see you there as well. So thank you so much. We'll be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them
真正关心自己的健康，这感觉真的很棒。他们关心自己的幸福。他们想了解心理学。这真是太棒了。我们确实拥有最棒的社群。非常感谢你们。如果你有节目建议，我差点忘了。请在 That Psychology Podcast 关注我。我喜欢听听你们的经历以及我们如何将一些科学应用其中。所以快来那边聊聊吧。快发送一个想法过来。我们希望在那里见到你。非常感谢你们。我们下周将带着另一集回归。嘿，各位好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你正在与
with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
一位知晓其道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我在我的播客《2%》中，剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。即 TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取自主行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重要时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived this. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年对我意义重大。我是 Sam J.，我是 Alex English。每一集里，我们都会邀请你来此，剖析发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过这一切的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保障人类。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。